Liberty Township Ohio I am headed your
way Friday February 16th and Saturday
February 17th Winnipeg my first time
headed your way I'll be there Friday
March 1st and Saturday March 2nd Omaha
we're going to do it this time I promise
you last time we got our flights
cancelled this time we're taking a
straight shot I'll be there Friday March
29th and Saturday March 30th Columbus
Ohio I'm fired up to head your way never
been there in my first time coming to
your beautiful city I'll be there Friday
April 12th and Saturday April 13th Los
Angeles I'm excited to announce that I'm
part of the Netflix is a joke Festival I
have my own show Sunday May 12th at The
Bourbon Room you guys ask me how come
you're not on Netflix well here's a
chance to sell this thing out and show
them why I should be get your tickets
now don't wait all tickets available at
Ryan sickler
[Music]
we going to be here all day we going to
be here all day baby I like this kind of
party welcome back to the way back I'm
Ryan sickler today's guest here in the
back seat with me Kevin Ryan everybody
hey now thanks for having to the way
back buddy thank you for being here
you're perfect for this show well first
of all tell me about growing up for you
cuz you told us on the Honeydew your
first and only memory of your parents
together was them sitting down to tell
you hey we're [__] out of here it's
over we tried it it didn't work yeah
that was my first my first memory is
them getting so so what are like
Vacations or growing up like are you
bouncing back and forth back and forth a
lot like we were split custody it was
good you know it was easy peasy for the
most part uh did you get the two
Christmases two Christmases which I
[__] loved like I look back now and
it's like people are like divorce was
the best thing that happened to my
family they would have killed each other
or something you know what I mean and
plus you know I got two Christmases you
know what I mean I got to and my dad
would really cuz he was the one who was
there was where there was money at times
so he would really show out and really
try to like and I would play I'd be like
Mom can I get a mini bike and she'd be
like no and then my dad would pick me up
and like Mom said I can't get a mini
bike he's like [__] Merry Christmas
budy wi8 today dude I used it for BB
guns like anything fireworks tell me
what was your bb gun do you first BB gun
was um the Red Rider the re really like
the one I think they might have branded
it after that or something I I I forget
exactly but it was the Red Rider BB gun
the Wen thing you know the one pump it
was just one pump it wasn't one of those
like that you pump 10 times just like
the quick action then I wanted some you
know some walking around steel so I got
a
handgun I I needed a sidearm in case
went South uh seven you know
what had a holster for it was it a
pellet gun or no it wasn't it was the
CRA I think it was called like the
Craftsman Bullseye or something it's it
looked like a Glock it was all black and
it had the thing pull back
and then push in and that like loaded it
um you pour the cart of milk carton of
BB's in it y yep yep and then um uh
after that I got there was this it was
sick dude it was like it had a clip in
the back that you put or on the top or
something it held SE 16 shots man you
couldn't I thought I Wasing Magnum PI
you couldn't tell me dude dude we had um
it's funny our parents my dad gave us
guns knives it's a daisy 880 temp pump
yeah with the scope too yeah there it is
multi- pump still out yeah that's the
standard thatal gun yeah that was that's
still their standard and it's got temp
pump but it's also the BB gun or pellets
you could individual pellets or could
pour the the pellets were a clear
indication that you didn't have both
parents the kids didn't had those that
was a dead giveaway that Mom and the dad
wearing in the picture nobody came from
a good home with one Christmas that had
aing pelic gun dude nobody that kid was
from the wrong side of the tracks dude
that was us bro that was us yeah that
was like you were getting ready to
[__] stick up a liquor store or
something D we would play BB tag with
these things we did that too as you got
older we would put cookie sheets on our
front and back and it was supposed to be
one pump and you could see it if it's
one pump you can see it coming yeah yes
but everybody was 10 pumping that
mother yeah yeah that was yeah I mean
there was nothing
I don't know if the kids have it now I
don't have kids I don't know but like
the T the back in the day the time you
would have you would just have like your
parents at to work in the summer it's
like yeah had 12 hours or whatever with
nothing to do and two BB guns it's like
what did you how did you think that day
was going to end what was a day like for
you in the summer you get up you go
outside cuz you're out in the suburbs
there out in the BBS uh are you bike
riding and playing ball or you just
going in the woods did you guys have
Woods Woods do Big Woods
wood what's going in the woods as a
younger kid before like smoking and
drinking the woods was great you were
you were building a treehouse in the
woods you'd find like a little creek a
rope swing I my leg out real bad on a
rope swing I was eight was the last day
of school June 17th I was yeah it was
last day of third grade went to the
woods my friend's older brother and his
the you know a couple older kids they're
going R swing and on this R swing they
found from you know probably generations
of teenagers ahead of them mhm uh it's
like 2 miles back in the woods down a
huge hill we ride our bikes down there
we fly down there and it was like a
celebration last day we're going to jump
in the you know rope swinging and we
were doing it it was fine and then I
jumped out like up the tree without the
Rope like just to jump in the water to
like rinse off I think that's what it
was and I went down with my knee bent
and I hit a route or like a rock or
something and it [__] exploded like
leg filled with Creek Water look like a
shark bite like yeah like horrible
that was me for the most part that was
that might have been me actually I don't
remember that I don't remember that two
piece back in the day got to keep the
girls in line you know what I
[Music]
mean uh and it just shattered your whole
knee it just blew it up like knee bones
sticking out I remember like seeing I
could see like down this fall it was
like hanging over cuz it was so much FL
it was looked horrible but now we're
back in the woods and I can't get out
like cuz and it's downhill like it's got
to we drove down so we got to go uphill
and everybody would push their bikes up
so I'm like I'm [__] stuck so luckily
my buddy was uh I mean we used to
ridicule him dude in the 90s he was in
the Boy Scouts and I mean we just
[__] ridiculed him what in high
school still in the but no we're eight
and we're making fun of them like we
didn't it wasn't even cool then like
that's how much of savages we were yeah
we were never it's like you're trying
what are you doing always felt like what
are we doing over there with these Boy
Scouts it's like take that vest off get
a s like [__] do something so luckily
he was there man and he saved my leg he
was like dude he kicked into [__]
Scouts Honor mode it was like I saw I
saw a picnic bench like two clicks back
and he [__] SC clicks I turn around
got the full badge on like this is a job
for [__] mad everybody shut I'm
listening Matt's [__] calling the
shots around here slapping people around
who aren't listening so he [__] runs
back he gets the uh he gets the picnic
bench he kicks the legs off of it get
the [__] out I swear eighty old he might
be seven I was he was probably seven I'm
going get that badge I'm going get this
badge dude they put me on it and he
located a h i remember made a stretcher
out of it for Christ sake Civil War my
fat ass I'm probably like a buck 80 at
the time I need six [__] seveny olds
to carry me you for Christ's sake so
they wrapped it up and they made a cut
They Carried me at the same time he was
he sent somebody there was a house that
we drove past like deep in the woods
that he sent someone to that
house they drove their car as far as
they could get it it was an old woman
she was like 80 and they put me in the
back of her car and she drove me out and
then we get to my buddy's house and his
mom was a little you know loopy and she
saw it and then my mom shows up just so
happened to be picking me up at that
time like we all converged at the house
at the same time and she's like I was
just getting ready to take Kevin to the
hospital my mom's like what happened
she's like he cut his knee in the woods
he needs a maybe a butterfly stitch or
two dude I'm talking it look like it
looked like somebody put a h grenade in
my knee and then my mom's like okay
didn't open it up it was still wrapped
up so we get to the we get to the
hospital and I was like do you think you
can walk in I'm like I don't know this
is pretty bad like let me see it
dude she faints it's like she's like but
she like [__] dude she she was told
it was a couple butterfly stitches and
then she's like my son's leg is dangling
off she runs in get me you know whatever
I ended up having I asked the doctor I
said how many stitches he goes I stopped
counting after a thousand a thousand cuz
they had to do layers layers and layers
and layers you tear muscle I lost
onethird of my patella tendon and
something else I for did they rebuild it
did they give you a kadav or anything no
they just like [__] are you limited
on that can you run no yeah it's all
good I'm pretty good you know for what
I'm doing you know what I mean I
probably couldn't make the Olympic team
but I'm all right did you ever rope
swing again never rope swing again but
uh it was one of those things I didn't I
was too fat to be doing that like I
tried to skateboard for years I was like
I'm too I I was like a imagine I had the
body of like a 30-year-old plumber
trying to jump downstairs it's like what
are you doing man yeah I'm trying to
like kick flip and it's like I'm you
know I got the ass of a [__] of a
plumber so that didn't I just kept
getting hurt my whole life and that yeah
well you said you had the injuries
growing up what other injuries uh did my
[__] the my hands I was
to here so I broke this bone and it's
called like your navicular your scaffo
bone or something it's the bone that
holds all the rest of the whenever I it
wasn't like I just broke my radius or
something it was like whatever you did
you blew it the [__] up it's like you
did the thing that you
the worst thing possible um so I had
surgery on that I was in a cast for 2
years with that all through but like
still I was like doing bike jumps and
stuff like like a [__] idiot um that
had a bone graft there's a screw still
in there and then this I had like you
know do you ever see like people have
the halo around their head a friend had
that I had that around my arm they call
it an external Fixit her so there was
two rods coming out here and two coming
out here did that I was in college no I
was in I'm sorry I was in high school
2005 [__] Eagles were in the Super
Bowl Super Bowl Sunday I was [__]
snowboarding a big boulder Jack Frost in
the Pocono Mountains Poconos Poconos and
uh me and my buddy were doing one trick
you know we were just we were
snowboarding for half the day it was
Super Bowl Sunday we're going to drive
home that night and go to a party and uh
I fell the last run like that's you know
the last jump into the the creek when I
hurt my knee that was the last jump the
last run I [__] my arm up and this
bone came it didn't bre break the skin
but it [__] it was like that was that
like a 45° angle had like that little
cage around it yeah but when I broke it
when I fell they were like you have to
go like I went to like the ski tent or
whatever you know the Snow Patrol and
they were like but we're bring the bring
the ambulance around like you need to go
to the hospital now and I was like yo
the birds are in the [__] Super Bowl
I've broken enough bones that I know no
one's going to do [__] on Super Bowl
Sunday night like they're going to say
you got to see an orthopedic on Monday
or something you're going to be happy
about or she if got to be in there
working on you yeah well [__] it I told
my buddy I said bring the car around
we're [__] going home called my buddy
on the way home who had a painkiller
addiction he squared me away with
one [__] Dr Feelgood met me at my
house [__] 23m watched the game got
up the next morning went to the [__]
hospital and had surgery like the next
day or whatever and that's when they put
all that [__] in there how long was that
on [__] 8 weeks or something senior
in high School [__] Birds lost no it
wasn't it was but uh it just like yeah
it just really it was [__] it was
garly I was always doing [__] I
shouldn't have been doing in the woods
[__] bike jumps all that [__] as a
kid very adventurous but like I said was
so out of shape and so fat no upper body
strength I couldn't do anything yeah
that that's what I had oh [__] like that
off the top not all the way around I
imagined it being cage n just that but
mine was bent so like there was actually
double the amount of bars cuz it went up
and it's what
straightening yeah I don't know what the
[__] they do I don't know why they had
to do it and it worked huh it worked
yeah I I don't have any any learing
issues I'm sure [__] arthritis is
going to kick in around 50 and jam me up
I'm feeling every bit of that yeah but
it's like that that was the [__] I had
man that [__] brings back bad
memories having my mom [__] butt in
my pants and [__] in the morning as a
senior in high school dude B and plus I
got like a gut and she's going do you go
under it or above I'm just [__]
button them lady the [__] button in your
pants sucked sucked dude just constantly
hurt but I was very like I said very
adventurous I was kind of left to my own
devices early on cuz split in time like
I thought I was at my mom she was
working you know lat key kid I would
wake up Summer 12 years old wake up we
were skateboarding and biking around
that time I'd you know probably hop on
my bike and bike to my buddy's house was
probably like 30 minute bike ride away
it was you know a 2-minute car ride but
in the suburb so it's like you know
[__] humping it go over there his
parents were gone I think like his
grandom would be there to watch the
younger siblings or something steal a
couple of Her sigs Go off into the woods
you know we'd have like five bucks
between both of us we'd get you know
slice of pizza or whatever for lunch
we'd just be gone for hours hours that's
all we did we go out you didn't call you
went to their house you knocked on their
you tried to get a pitcher a batter two
infielders two outfiters if we could get
five on a team we would play automatic
out if you don't [__] opposite Fields
an automatic out you got to pull it
uhhuh and then that's how we play half
baseball we would you figure it out
capture the flag that [__] was the best
fors did you ever uh it's so funny when
I grew up we had streams all through
Maryland we called it cray fishing back
then we'd lift up the rocks and crayfish
and then
I come to learn they're crawfish sure we
called them crayfish back I've heard
both I've heard crayfish and crawfish I
didn't know I thought they were two
different things they're the same thing
they're the same [__] thing bro we
used to go in rivers all the time little
streams in Maryland and you have to just
gently pick up rocks super slow and
they're under there and then you got to
[__] scoop them with a bucket or
something they swim backwards like
lobster and [__] but they're fun to fun
to [__] try to catch but we would
every now and then you get one big fat
you like oh [__] baby Lobster yeah I
mean I do now but then I didn't no we
were just kids catching you you only
catch like one or two you cook one or
two ripping them apart and ripping their
[__] claws off you know [__]
swinging them from a rope and [__] and
something a a crayfish never thought it
would do but man we would catch big ones
and then we would put them in like a
bucket and just watch them and [__] and
give it a little bit of food and stuff
we throw them in our fish tank like the
neighborhood kids had fish we throw them
in the fish tank fresh water look fill
the time that's it dude looking to fill
the time dude we would build ramp be
Nest you ever [__] with beest what dude
we found this one behind a WWA there we
go man it was the size of a [__] five
gallon bucket yeah dude and we went to
war with this thing for weeks weeks in
the summer what you H you running up and
hitting it with sticks or so high up it
was like 20 we were just in the woods we
had no tools so we just rocks you're
just chucking rocks close everybody
would get close right you creep up and
you go all right one two like you'd
start running before it even left your
hand and man you we you it was we never
got it down it I'm telling you it was 2
and 1/2 ft probably been there for 30 or
whatever you know untouched it' be
winging [__] rocks at it and you
would hit it man and you would see them
like fly out of the hole come gunning
for you dude they know right we're
hitting the deck we're [__] jumping
behind logs and [__] dude we used to
[__] with we would get them on our house
so they build them up underneath the the
gutter or whatever and it sometimes you
get mud wasps that would build that
little mud Trail on the wall those you'd
get Hornets we'd get yellow jackets but
we would try to take the hose we'd hook
it up outside but then go in the house
and Pull It in so we can get through the
window and and try to shoot those
[__] or raid them or whatever
light them on fire did my car got bees
the last car I had had bees to get bees
it was sitting in it was it was my
Mercury Montego was sitting at my mom's
at my parents house for for a minute cuz
I was in New York I couldn't afford to
keep it there the parking tickets the
whole n yards um so I was like all right
I'm going back I'm going to bring it up
and man this thing I opened the trunk
[__] these things came at me quick when
I was like talking I'm like yeah
yeah dude I ran into the garage and I I
got raid or some some sort of chemical
I'm a big just get the closest chemical
yeah Raid kill them [__] pledge will
kill them they're going to get fantastic
going to kill little fabuloso Fabuloso
and dude yeah I just DED the back of my
tri and my car smelled like [__] for it
just smelled like chemicals for you know
the next three years but man I remember
that God damn seventh grade we had a
science project we were supposed to go
collect something from the neighborhood
uh my brother Derek and our buddy at the
time Steve Sani uh we all go out into
the great childhood friend last name
there there's a whole family of the
senon great people they're great people
we go out into this little stream out
back and we decide we're going to catch
you know just whatever dirt and sediment
and [__] from the stream we're going to
bring it in the class is going to look
at it and then I'm pretty sure it was my
brother is like we should be in
this and I'm in seventh grade and I'm
like we should definitely be in this but
we're in science class could they tell
like I'm in my mind like can they tell
it's
RP DNA test it dude we take a like a
margarine thing we go out we scoop and
we all three piss in it okay we put the
lid on on it we take it into class and
every week all week they're doing these
things but ours doesn't get picked till
like Thursday and when he opened that
lid up that's smells like a bathroom and
Sh Stadium this one here and we're just
looking at each other we are D all the
kids are [__] dropping it on the
microscope they studying it we
pissed man that's Dev P it's ridiculous
so stupid just pissed all in it and then
we're touching it we're in there touch
like yeah look at all those things
moving in there dude we were like I said
big I haven't thought about the woods in
years man Big Woods even snakes you [__]
with snakes I didn't [__] with snakes
but we built we would always so we were
in the suburbs and there was always
construction happening because like you
know the people were moving out of the
city and there was just new developments
going up so we would go rans sack the
[__] the developments for materials
tools we'd be [__] we'd put it on
skateboards or whatever and like push it
down Main to get back into the woods
carry back and just build forts man that
was another
thing we would [__] up [__] the
construction sites looking back I mean
we would [__] them up dude we found as
like 11year olds three pallets full of
caul and you couldn't tell a
[__] man that [__] went everywhere dude
we were coing the key holes to the
backos we were [__] just sming it on
the wall then putting tools on the wall
I mean we were that's great but like
that's what we're just filling time it's
like oh you know we got 30 packs of
[__] caul my brother was more my twin
so I have two brothers I have a younger
brother and I have a twin brother my
twin brother is fraternal twin so one
day I'm out cutting the grass it's my
turn to cut the grass and the neighbor
mom is yelling at me like you [__]
son of a [__] and I'm like whatever
lady and she's like you shot my bird
feeder I'm like I don't even what the
[__] you're talking about but she's so
ad I've shot this bird feeder I'm not
thinking anything but [__] you [__] I
didn't shoot your bird feeder I'm not
thinking anything else but I didn't
shoot your bird feeder so I go in my
brother and our friend time Jeff Wagner
they're playing Nintendo 64 I'm like
[__] lady next door yelling at me
about shooting her bird feed her and
they start dying laughing I'm like you
[__] pieces of [__] I'm like what are
you doing like we've been sitting in
dad's room cuz they his my dad had a
side window and it went right over to
their deck and she had to bir feed her
just pet gun it through the [__] well
she she knows so these [__]
think it's so funny that I'm getting
yelled at for it and then we put the
motor on the boat cuz we're going
crabbing in the morning sure and we run
to the store and we come back guess what
ain't on the boat anymore the motor the
motor and guess who [__] took it that
old [__] not only her she had two like
20 some year old sons that knew and they
took
that my dad my dad's like what the [__]
happened my brother ain't saying [__]
why don't you tell him about that
[__] birdfeed you all been shooting
over there you [__] damn stole
the [__] motor snakes dude yeah stole
the motor he would my brother would
catch snakes bring them in the house
there was one time where we went to the
doctor for my younger brother my
mother's like you guys coming in we're
like we're sitting in the car my brother
and I in the back seat they get out
we're still sitting in the back seat
this [__] reaches in his pocket
and pulls out a snake [__] I'm like
where where are you getting that he's
like it was in a bush out front before
we left but he was always like that yeah
didn't care wasn't scared of any of that
[__] didn't give a [__] about any of it
I had a pet snake one time my cousin
came my cousin worked at a pet shop and
like I guess someone the story I heard
was like someone traded in a snake for
something else like they had a snake and
they were like I want that lizard he
like all right well I can do 50 and the
snake type thing 50 I'll give you the
beard of dragon you snake so he got this
snake and he gave it to me for my
birthday and we had it in like a 20
gallon aquarium like from that we had
from like a fish tank or something put
it in the
aquarium and then that same night like
that night he gave it to me we go to bed
we wake up and had babies overnight and
they little they're like this big but
they can crawl up through the [__]
vents [__] I didn't think that they're
all over the kitchen counter no how many
it it seemed like
60 snakes little [__] they were they
were like this big Fu that just dude
they were in the fruit bowl in the on
the Martin's potato they were all over
in the sink they were everywhere dude my
mom was flipping the I work all goddamn
day to come home to snakes like who gets
snakes people get M we had snake dude we
were find them for [__] and then you
got to go to the pet store and get the
baby mice and feed the [__] snakes
nah we did that my mom's like you're
getting rid of this [__] first of all
the snake is staying in the garage or
out back she's no longer allowed in the
house one night my brother had a black
snake in an aquarium downstairs and it
got out and all I wanted to do the night
that we're going to the next day we've
got a we get a black rubber snake and we
want to sneak in her room and just just
lay it on the bed and then just not even
aggressively just
to and hit her with it and that [__]
day there's a guy that comes over and we
got a deep freeze down in the basement
where we keep our meats and our bull
lips for crabbing the bushel basket cuz
why wouldn't you keep those two things
together and uh we hear this dude and my
brother goes my snake he knew right away
he runs down [__] dude found a snake
and I was like God damn it I can't do
that [__] to Mom yeah that's [__] up
yeah God damn these sickers play Fist
and lo my brother one time he seene from
Kill Bill anyway this is how my brother
was the snake ends up killing this
little rat it doesn't you know it won't
eat anything dead it kills it my
brother's like [__] that I spent my
grass cutting money so ties fishing
string to the rat's tail and he just
starts making it dance in the cage and
that [__] snake he's the guts are
coming out of it and he finally [__]
eats the thing and I was like God damn
my brother had reached in and the snake
bit him and I'll I still to this day
I'll never forget this this [__]
I told him if that snake would have bit
me i' been like I'm going to the
hospital he didn't even look he didn't
even look at it he just he just looked
right at the snake like I was like
you're a [__] psychopath I ain't got
that Gene in me I like SN I don't like
birds I don't like nothing birds are too
unpredictable well no one should have a
pet bird anyway pet birds no I'm talking
even pigeons there's one in my building
that's lost and I'm like that's gone oh
yeah that's gone lost hey reward if you
find it that Bird is Gone anybody post
lost bird I'm like your bird's gone man
yeah people have loose birds as pets is
[__] nuts I'll never understand that
walk into a house like that's my [__]
you're like [__] yeah unless the door
gets open [__] me or the coatu buddy
I I don't I'm not even that good of
friends with you got any Ghost Stories
the only thing well there was one I was
staying at a I was doing a show in uh I
think Foley was with us we were doing a
show I don't know if this was the same
time or not doing a show in upstate
Pennsylvania in like Easton or something
like Allentown up that way and uh we
were staying at this place called the SE
mansion and it was a haunted Airbnb a
haunted bed and breakfast same anytime
you hear that [__] the were the rooms
named after a person I don't remember
like Delila oh dude if it was I wasn't I
that's where we were bro so there was
what there was like five of us staying
in the one room one of those gigs of
like we'll give you a hundred bucks and
a hotel room like cool yeah there it is
the say your mansion and um look ha to
dude yeah I know like they you walk in
they're like welcome to the Haunted
Mansion or what you're like [__] this I
don't like I'm not a guy who believes in
ghost unless I'm staying at a [__]
Haunted Mansion you know what I mean
like right now I don't believe in ghost
but at the say Mansion my [__] head's
on a swivel so we're asking and like
they have the stories in the the in the
lobby of like this 8-year-old died here
this 10-year-old died here this
30-year-old di like seven I mean this
they've been people just been dying in
this place so then I go uh dude we were
taking an Uber back from I think I was
getting pizza or something for everybody
we're all meeting back after the show
and this taxi driver I'm like do you
know anything about he's like you're
staying at theayer Mansion I'm like oh
[__] me dude and he's like yeah I'm like
is that place haunted he's like no and
I'm like what he goes I like did you
ever see anything weird there and he's
like no he goes he goes I used to be a
partment I lived there for like 5 years
in the'80s I'm like you ever seen
anything weird there anything I should
be afraid of and he's like nah I go
nothing weird he's like nah he's like
well my roommate was stabbed to death in
the bathroom I'm
like I had I had to press you to [__]
remember that like that wasn't like yeah
he gave you oh yeah oh yeah yeah I
forgot about this yeah and I he's like
I'm like what the [__] he's like yeah no
I was dispute over money or something
I'm like okay we got back to that Airbnb
dude we took we took turns staying up
like every hour we got back to ours I I
packed up the family in the middle of
the night later at 1:00 a.m. I was like
we're out of here we're out you can
sleep on the ride home we're out I get
that we got too drunk and I think we
were like we'll all just get drunk and P
like you know pass out but somebody had
to somebody stayed up the whole entire
time and like we got up with that sun up
and got the [__] out of there dude thank
you for doing this this has been great I
appreciate it plug and promote
everything you'd like yeah uh our
podcast is are you garbage it's wherever
you get your podcast there um and also
that we're on tour right now we do uh
stand up comedy we co-headline me and uh
me and H Foy co-headline and then play a
with the crowd it's a good time gang
check it out at Kevin R comed on all
social media and rug garbage uh.com for
tickets and episodes hell yeah all right
as always Ryan cercom Ryan sickler all
social media talk to y'all next
[Music]
week
oh